oh have we talked about hanami at all
like the cherry blossom thing sir i mean
like so i i i mean you've you know you
you watch anime right you know what
cherry the cherry is awesome you know
what [ __ ] cherry blossoms i will lie
i was slightly disappointed to find out
that cherry blossoms are only around for
like one week and they [ __ ] off because
i'm like hold out there and
all the anime all the time what's going
on with that yeah they film all the
anime in the same week i realized it's
like a cult in japan like they they're
obsessed with this the anime like
everything revolves when hanami's coming
up everything is hanami yeah like well
yeah everything has to become cherry
blossom it's like everything everyone
just joins like a caller it's because
there's a really like extensive history
right right but it's like it's nuts like
it's i understand why it's an anime so
much now but when i got here i'm like
wow literally everything is decorated
like it's a call of duty gun skin it's
like
everything's there every it doesn't
matter what it is it gets a cherry
blossom skin i mean not gonna lie man
like a good honey is [ __ ] dark yeah
yeah but it's good it's it is
disappointing it's really warm
i did miss hanami this week yeah this
year this year
i'm sorry
i didn't do anything this year because i
i i totally forgot i didn't know when it
was coming i i had one of the best
harmonies this year i'd rather enjoy it
because we went to [ __ ] hakone for it
and like all along the hakuna river it's
just like rows and rows of soccer trees
do you want to explain what hanoi is to
the viewers yes
literally means flower watching yeah in
japanese so it's it's basically this
kind of i wouldn't even say it's like a
festival it's more like an event that
happens isn't it even a public holiday
no i feel like it's a mutual agreement
amongst everyone to get drunk in the
park yeah that's kind of what it is
pretty much pretty much but it's yeah
it's like because the sucker are only
around for about a week and some maybe
sometimes not even a week later a couple
of days uh people go out and like
celebrate by just sitting under a tree
having a picnic under the sucker tree do
you think it's [ __ ] great do you
think it's worth because i know a lot of
people who are like i want to come to
japan during that time do you think it's
worth coming to japan just for it i
think because i think if it's the first
time you come into japan i think it's
worth yeah i think now because we've
lived in japan for two years we're kind
of like
we're kind of like used to it but i feel
like seeing hanami for the first time
and seeing like all like the cherry
blossoms just like falling off the trees
and you have like the ground is
literally covered in cherry blossoms
yeah like everywhere i think that's a
pretty cool like a couple of weeks
definitely just nodded to you saying
that right now
it's like in the end
like you literally walk through a park
and it's lit it is literally like every
[ __ ] anime scene where like you the
[ __ ] cherry blossoms yeah the cherry
blossoms everywhere fluttering down
still looks dope it looks dope as [ __ ] i
like
i don't know what it is japan that just
it's like so aesthetic but it's just
it's just the perfect aesthetic i mean
japan is like kind of aesthetic all year
round but i'd say like the most
aesthetic is probably during the sakura
i'd say if you are going to do it
definitely get out of tokyo because like
every single hanami place in tokyo like
every single park that has the cherry
blossom trees is this packed
yeah like you you will be like because
we met two years ago we did like a small
one yeah and we had to get like a corner
of dirt
in the park right next to the road like
it was the only literally the only spot
left in this massive where did you guys
go like shinjuku no we we're in uh
saitama yeah yeah yeah and it was like
it was rammed as well it was so full
because what what people normally do
here in japan is during the cherry
blossom week or season or when they're
blooming uh people go to the park they
get like a kind of like a picnic area um
and then they just get [ __ ] pissed in
public right right it's great i'd say go
like when you come to japan definitely
do like a week in tokyo and then if
you're if you're you know if it aligns
with the hanami do a week somewhere else
where you can then go and celebrate the
hanami yeah i feel like doing because
you can't really explore japan in one
week i don't think no you can't you kind
of explore tokyo in one week yeah true i
feel i've only been here for like two
years now and i've barely explored japan
how is hanami in like hakuna you said oh
i mean it's great because it's like i
mean hakuna is still you know very much
a tourist destination but i mean
compared to like shinjuku go in or like
yogi park it's like yeah you don't get
any space at all no absolutely no space
at all and i mean like i i guess as well
like in hakone in a lot of places in
hakone they've definitely like
positioned a lot of like uh onsens and
like yorkans and stuff like that yeah
around the sakura and like around all
the aesthetic parts of hakone so
yeah it was great i mean like we we
stayed in like an airbnb that was
overlooking uh like a bunch of like
sakura trees on the lake and yeah in the
distance you could see mount fuji and it
was like the most like aesthetic [ __ ]
hanami that i ever had and i was like
you know what it's it's kind of worth to
go all the way out there sometimes to
just like get a little bit of peace of
mind right because otherwise it's just
be like you'd be robbing shoulders with
the person next to you being like look
at the pedal over there oh my god yeah
it wasn't the people it was like the
[ __ ] kids running around i mean like
getting pissed is great getting pissed
with like a bunch of like five
six-year-olds running around you like
playing football or whatever
it's not exactly like the best kind of
vibe to get pissed drunk if you're
sitting like where i am now you are
probably like this close to someone as
well yeah someone else is like
matt and picnic set